[Musique]
j'ai assez impressionné quand même déjà
mis autant de gangsters autour des quais
c'est un rêve d'enfant d'être un
gangster
mais bien sûr je rêve de tous les deux
tout les enfants d'être d'être un
gangster de quoi bien sûr mais moi j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être un gangster orléans
dans la vie soit tu gères folle idée
c'est de la merde
soit une baltringue moi aussi j'ai un
peu d'angleterre et même des tissus plus
enfants père qui fendent je vais une
gangsters et d'avoir une scène avec un
fusil à pompe
j'ai envie de dire c'est la vrai
gangster dames c'est vrai regard de
femme rappelle noir n'est pas à l'aise
avec les gens
tu m'as chamakh et madame ce c'était une
évidence de l'avoir en bandits dans ce
film pas tout de suite parce que
j'aurais aimé que ce soit une évidence
tout de suite ça - simplifier la tâche
mais j'ai quand j'ai commencé à être
plus au fait de ce qui faisait un soir
j'ai vu son spectacle voilà voilà sur m6
et je l'aimé bien mais j'avais pas
encore regardé tu vois où je m'étais
posé vraiment précisément sur ce qu'il
faisait et en voyant le spectacle j'ai
trouvé qu'on avait une connexion comme
ça sur l'enfance qui m'a beaucoup plu et
tout de suite j'ai demandé un rendez
vous qu'on puisse se rencontrer et se
parler de boulot et c'était un rendez
vous qui était super et tout de suite
les choses ont avancé sapa presse a pas
traîné
ok donc là moi j'ai passé de la drogue
je viens d'avoir un coup de coeur pour
toi tu pars demain matin stade
accueillera tu me ramènes un petit
paquet mois moi je voudrais déjà vous
dire merci beaucoup pour cette
proposition d'emploi quand même c'était
une ville très agréable c'était c'est
une ville haute en couleurs voilà
évidemment c'est pas une ville qu'on qui
ressemble à d'autres villes en europe
donc forcément c'était et à filmer et à
et à vivre pour le tournage c'est
particulier ce qui m'intéresse c'est
votre parcours est ce que vous étiez en
étant jeune plutôt studieux où cancre
comme dans le film
les profs a sorti en 2013 de pierre
françois martin laval dans lequel vous
avez joué j'étais plutôt michmich mi
cuite comme by perçu lieu mais pas non
plus naze j'ai toujours eu la moyenne
pour pas de mareuil me saoule c'était
comment la faculté de droit
c'était court mais quand c'est flou
c'est donner deux trois notions de
business sur des cons appareils sur
lesquels tu as 25 ans moi je me souviens
que quand je voyais les films pour ados
de même encore maintenant quand même pas
mal d'ados autour de moi ils sont très
contrarié en général de ne pas se
retrouver dans les films français quand
ils vont voir les jeunes américains ils
voient super g ils sont très contents
ils disent ah ben c'est ça les
conversations les conversations de cul
qu'on a avec mes potes et tout ça
pourquoi les films en témoigne page du
bac aucun film français le fait mais ça
c'était un des premiers soucis puis
après c'est vrai que le ton et je le dis
est assez transgressif c'est à dire que
si vous avez des enfants en bas âge
recommande pas le film c'est en bas âge
ses six ans et pas un film pour les
enfants de 6 ans mais aussi parce que je
trouve qu si aujourd'hui le débat le
cinéma aux sphères en salle et c'est
assez corsetée et je trouve que c'est le
contraire de ce à quoi doit servir
décidément société ça veut pas dire que
faire des films vulgaire pour se sentir
libre mais je trouve que c'est une des
libertés qu'il faut utiliser moi ça
m'amusait pour l'expression de choquer
le bourgeois quoi de dire voilà tout le
monde ya des gens qui vont faire gros et
c'est une autre manière de se marrer de
faire des eaux au et rigoler un peu
derrière et vous vous êtes bien amusé on
sent l'ambiance lors entre vous
finalement à l'écran et en dehors vous
êtes pote ben c'est sûr que d'être à
amsterdam
pendant la première moitié du tournage
presque un mois moins une semaine
bah du coup ça c'est sûr que ça nous a
aidés à se souder
on se connaissait non non on se
connaissait s'étaient jamais rencontrés
on a des histoires communes parce qu'on
a des parcours tous un peu on est de la
même génération on a commenté tous ils
on eu la même ville en at on a commencé
on a commencé jeune donc dès qu'on
creuse de seconde on a des amis en
commun on a des ddd commencé du temps
comme un malaxeur commun voilà on a un
florilège de chansons
merci ce sera à découvrir le 29 marat là
et gangsters d'art
le 29 mars partout en france
vive le val de loire et la photo